The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So we're given
this definition for car.
We saw that on the
previous slide.
I want to add a
method that's going
to change the color of the car,
and these are my four choices.
And it looks like you
guys are getting it
right, which is awesome.
So to find a method to change
the color of the car, which
does this.
So we know that self has
to be the first parameter,
so we can automatically
eliminate A and C
and it's between B
and D. And remember
I said you have to be conscious
about whose data attribute
you're accessing,
and in this case,
we want to change the color of a
particular instance of the car,
right?
So we have to say self.color
instead of just color.
If we just said
color, then color
would refer to just a
variable inside the class,
not a data attribute
of a particular object.